[Musik]
animal crossing ist ein spiel das ich
damals in meiner kindheit immer gespielt
habe weil meine schwester mal gespielt
hat und wir uns in der es geteilt haben
und das war dann halt immer ein
schwieriges thema auf jeden fall habe
ich vor einigen tagen auf dem zweit
kanal schon mal kurz animal crossing
gespielt du wirst du auch stimmt ja von
daher spielen wir hier jetzt heute
weiter und zwar sagt tom luca lo
miteinander hier spricht tom nun zeit
für eine insel durchsage mit allen
neuigkeiten von der insel menschen aber
vage
[Musik]
ich werde ankündigungen machen die sehr
wichtig für das leben hier sind also
ohren auf ja ja heute gibt es keine
neuigkeiten warum soll ich dann meine
ohren aufmachen also gebe ich euch einen
tipp zum leben auf lauf statt
also habe ich meine insel genannt habt
ihr freude am basteln hymne eigentlich
absolut gar nicht wenn ihr euch damit
noch nicht befasst habe dem service
center gibt es eine kostenlose
einführung dann weiß ich auf jeden fall
wo ich nicht hingehen werde das ist laut
stadt da unten eine kleine animation und
das hier ist auch meine lieben freunde
vor seiner villa post ich habe post kann
ich ihnen
ja genauso
ich habe absolut keine ahnung was wir
jetzt als nächstes machen müssen
wahrscheinlich die ganze zeit einfach um
40 warum laufen
aha hier sicher ein ast wow ich bin
locker jetzt schon der beste in dem
crossing spieler allerdings würde ich
sagen entdecken weil es erst mal unsere
insel hier so ein bisschen hier ist
wasser vielleicht da hatte ich
eigentlich durch das was noch nie
brauche ich dafür gummistiefel spiele
auch kummer meinen axel friese
das ist auf jeden fall unsere insel hier
aber zwei steine ist auch da hier vorne
aber noch mehr steine kann ich darauf
a-ha kummer ein haifisch aber gut meine
lieben freunde machen wir mal weiter
unseren strand spaziergang ist das sind
diamant das ist eine stachelige kann ich
die ich habe so fettig wolfskin hosen
alter passt alles reibung hat ja eine
person ihr haus aufgebaut
das ist nämlich sie hier und zwar heißt
sie nadine aber das war dann doch die
arme gegriffen
er steht jetzt aber wer ist der beste
sagte dass das sondern eigentlich sollte
er sonst eigentlich eher so ein berliner
akzent oder diese geste ob thumann
vogelpohl den nasen die herumlaufen ist
diese alles andere als einsam
gänseblümchen gänseblümchen die mich
dann brauchen wir jetzt auch einen
rahmen für die who der nämlich draußen
fahrer bist doch der coolste
danke ich ständig ständig nadine löst
dich hab ich zerbreche mir schon eine
weile den kopf über endes kam mit der
geistigen sitzende knallharter anleitung
für den durch josef blättchen schirm ja
das ist dort hat die menschheit braucht
sich nadine danke das sticht einem war
ich gerade wieder auf der insel sala
erstes team zu hause ganz klar das
unkraut eigentlich ich weil ich so
brillant hübsch bin halt der anblick
allein war inspiration zu dieses
knallharte passt du musst dich nicht
bedanken
ich hätte mich auch nicht bedankt wenn
du dich noch nicht ans basteln getraut
hat kaum halten kann
hey tom luca ich wollte nicht nur kurz
an und war knapp aber ich muss echt kein
einziges mal lachen organisiert
kostenlosen schnupperkurs im service
center konnte erst nicht glauben alles
klar ich weiß wo ich definitiv nicht hin
laufen werde schauen wir mal ihre villa
hier können wir da scheint niemand hier
zu sein ja ach nee weil die nadine davon
unterm baum stehen die parteien aber gut
hatten diesen kesha
nachdem gelaufen war ganz langsam hinter
nadine her und ich war
ich wollte hier mir nur das unkraut
anschauen
das werden wir auf den schlips getreten
wenn man kann doch mit mir reden ja
nadine ich heißt diese komischen
bläschen da das liebe ich jetzt nicht
mag
spox auf die fresse rotzen kurz alles
was du zu sagen hast tut mir leid als
wenn sie so mitbekommen hätte dass ich
tief erfolg und ihren kesha klauen will
ok habt ihr versehen bringen aber sowas
wäre noch mal alles klar
immer weg langsam nennt sich die nadine
umdreht das paar freue ich mich aber
wieder
ich will den cash hatte soll hinter der
härten sieht uns nicht
das unkraut auf ich will die cacher war
ein gott okay dann kümmern wir uns jetzt
erstmal hier um diesen ast den nehme ich
auch nochmal mit ich weiß zwar nicht was
weniger zu essen haben wollt euch seht
ihr die villa da hinten im mondlicht
im mondlicht es ist 17 25 grad im spiel
aber gut an zumal hier vorne den stock
und dann würde ich sagen wenn wir jetzt
auch mal so ein bisschen hier rum ich
will halt nicht in dieses komische
service hätte welche absolut kein bock
auf seine komischen schirm chor wieder
läuft online
jetzt ist die ja schon wieder vielleicht
beschwerte sich wieder aber gut laufe
normal weiter hier dann kann ich ja im
steinigen die der kann hier alles
einsammeln
das komplette unkraut das habe ich ihren
dein ziel in diesem spiel nicht dem
ablegen werden fasst billig wissen was
es überhaupt komplett kommen die google
jetzt mal blättchen schirm
danke nochmal er jetzt kommt die da
schon wieder jedoch deinen eigenen weg
nachdem das erregte schon wieder alles
auf die volle der schmetterlinge ich bin
doch ich habe für mein zelt eine echt
gute stelle erwischt danke es aber nicht
so gut wie meine wir sollten uns
weiterhin gegenseitig unterstützen mit
einem freund ist alles einfacher co
krakow können auch sein neuer
amerikanischer rapper sein soll in
krakow mit seinem neuen song lamborghini
ach ja ich habe hier was für dich als
dank für die hilfe mit dem zelt quatsch
sagt nicht der chef
die safari mit das perfekte lauf statt
geil
da schon ein blättchen skisafari hut ist
ja fast wie mein style in echt ne da bin
ich auch über sehr ausgefallen was
dauerten an
oh mein gott ich sehe damit aus wie
sandra mit ihrem fischers hut egal wer
es noch einen stachel schnecke mac ja
ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
so genau was sich irgendwie machen soll
kann man hier vorne läuft am new krummin
vorne schon zu ende habe ich nicht in
die eine karte
würd sagen ich nehme auch hier vorne den
ast mit dann nehme ich noch hier den
achten dass mal wieder das unkraut aber
hier ist nämlich auch noch mit hier
vorne
vielleicht kann ich damit ja irgendwann
mal ein lagerfeuer machen aber dem ich
dann mal in safari hut verbrennen kann
auch schön dich zu sehen schlepp ja ich
wünsche ich könnte das gleiche auch von
dir behaupten die arbeiten nachts im
service center also kommt einfach vorbei
falls mal irgendwas an liegt im moment
vertrete ich mir ein bisschen die beine
und schaue dass es auch allen hier gut
geht wenn du mal die den browser so
anstellen könnte sagt einfach bescheid
bro
das war der grund warum ich dich
angesprochen habe aber geh ruhig weg
macht geisteskrank spaß services rund um
die uhr geöffnet ja kommen dann würde
ich sagen schau mal einem servicecenter
vorbei ich mit meinem fetten
quadratschädel hier geschafft hast hier
laufen zwar noch die verworfen und
vorbereitungen aber eine handvoll
kleinigkeiten bieten wir schon an
wahnsinn da wir kaum lagerplatz haben
und so gibt es eigentlich auch täglich
neue sachen bei uns so rasch bestimmt
allerhand zu tun die tu ich habe so viel
zu tun mit demenz und claudio und so
schaut mal was es gibt vielleicht ist ja
was für dich dabei ich schau mal sage
ich dann einfach spitze
ihr habt einen wasserkühler unten
räucherofen und ich habe 00 wenn ihr
tipps habt für das spiel dann schickt
mir die gern postalisch zu nach köln ich
klicke jetzt mal einfach hier auf er
weil dann soll a ha wird ok noch immer
nicht weil ich noch mal kein geld aber
wir haben hier eine wackel angel wir
haben einen wackel kesha wir haben mit
einer wackel gießkannen ziemlich
wirklich bei euch alles kaufen hier
nicht nur wir kaufen auch sachen alles
was man so viel geld und weil eine
weitere insel was tolles für alle ist
darum zahlen wir auch ein paar stern ist
unkraut oder ein wahnsinn wenn du nicht
sicher bist ob wir etwas bestimmtes
ankaufen fragen kostet nichts und wo
immer wo kaufen wo verkaufen
die sachen das was im karton
kriegt er von dem ich geh dann mal ich
habe einen karton meine lieben freunde
wir brauchen jetzt richtige so
undercover mission impossible musik weil
ich habe zwar ich hatte mich mitgenommen
alvaro der dafür nicht sehen darf
ich weiß nicht ob das so ganz legal
waren also ganz vorsichtig langsam
je mehr zurückziehe trend kommt
ein student wegen rhein in unseren laden
das wird unser erstes richtiges
möbelstück was wir nicht also sieht das
übrigens bei mir ausnahme ziemlich
wohnlich
[Applaus]
da merkt man dass sich architektur
studieren wollte können wir jetzt
theoretisch den stein auch nehmen und
hier ablegen einfach warum spiele ich
das spiel hatte ich das heute wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch ein level crossing mit
mir mit luca gefallen hat dann das gern
einen daumen hoch unter dem video da
schreibt mir zu nehmen gern mal chips et
cetera und in die kommentare
denn ich glaube ihr seht schon dass ich
nicht so richtig den plan ab was nicht
da machen soll
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
schon im auto meiner lieben von ihm
kennen der ein smiley ein gelände für
den drauf klickt und noch kein abonnent
von meinem kanalseite könnt dann sei die
abonnent
wahnsinn und jetzt mein neuestes video
auf den zweiten kanal verlinkt
[Musik]
es endet bei mir heute im gelände mit
sprache